non juste le mettre sur pause ah ça
c'est un vidéo de filature quelques vous
avez pu s que vous en avez pris
connaissance de cette vidéo là
effectivement j'ai pris connaissance de
ce vidéo là et c'est un vidéo qui est
datée du 27 octobre 2008 à 11h17 du
matin c'est à quel endroit se trouve au
commerce grues guay l'entreprise grues
guay précisément hockey et l'entreprise
dont vous avez parlé que monsieur
monsieur la fortune ne fonctionne se
trouve à être actionnaires associés
cette compagnie a cessé cette compagnie
parfait alors on va laisser à des vidéos
et je vais vous demander de nous mettre
les chaussures pas ou ce quart partant
vers la gorge madrid identifier les gens
la personne à gauche avec les lunettes
fumées
vous voyez de profil le droit et raynald
desjardins lottin des individus de dos
je vais laisser progresser une vidéo
normal voire plus tard monsieur
d'identifier si vous voulez vous l'avais
dit je vous en avais déjà pris
connaissance assez qui bartolo et de
celui à droite et d'oxygène mais lequel
joe diop est excusé franchement vous
vous trompez de vidéos je vais vous
laisser vous voyez monsieur le droit de
discuter j'ai juste terminée si je sais
depuis que tu as la droite convoi de
visage doit faire face le ses progrès
cette vidéo
si on est capable de l'arrêter nota
porterait pas y revenir un petit peu une
offre à venir un petit peu
juste porter à votre pension moyenne
aisée le fait que monsieur dupuis dans
nos bacs
monsieur desjardins qui est sans être
sans aller dans les détails culturel ou
peu importe dans un milieu criminalisé
c'est une marque de notre affection de
familiarité de proximité je voulais dire
c'est que lorsqu'on est pas en reste
vous l'idée c'est bien ça continue et là
il ya un autre individu ce que vous
allez dire dessus étant tous là vous
avez confondu que monsieur bertolo mais
qui a fait une accolade
oui nicolas d'un des bars et des signes
de familiarité
monsieur boulet qui c'est monsieur mario
boulanger avait parlé tantôt c'est que
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure c'est pour ça
que je voulais attendre la prolongation
pour voir le visage et monsieur bull est
ce que vous avez dit une relation achats
c'est exactement ça qui est proche de
louis pierre lafortune et se diriger
vers la connaissent pas vous aurez
peut-être revenir un petit peu avant et
un individu qui va être dans le cadre de
portes demain seul bull identifier alors
il va y avoir une accolade monsieur
dupuis monsieur boulet oui là parce
qu'il chante liseret les mots le membre
en règle du chapitre de sherbrooke des
hells angels qui se trouve dans le
cadrage de porte
là je veux dire et je fais appel à votre
connaissance du crime organisé
motard italien on voit que monsieur
bulli et partira jouer je me suis ému et
elle se pose c'est une question pour
réseauter mot est à dire un joint de
monsieur monsieur bull est allé
rejoindre monsieur est mort mais il n'y
a pas eu de jeu d'éveil a pas eu de tuer
mon est resté d'un cadre de porte n'est
pas sortir un côté monsieur desjardins
moi je pourrais je peux présumer auprès
de vous que monsieur edmond s'il était
ciblé d'une enquête mettant à l'époque
font reculer d'antan en 2008 on était
réunie pendant chaque on était dans le
projet sharqc qui est un projet qui
visait les angels
c'est un projet qui était lié à un jazz
était dans l'actualité était sous
enquête
monsieur edmond mon interprétation est
qu'il ne veut pas amené de la chaleur
j'organisais veut pas mener la tension
policière à un individu comme je sais du
puits
raynald desjardins ou mario boulet lors
d'une d'une rencontre d'un stationnement
plus continuer
jocelyn dupuis quitter
je voulais vous quitter
ce moment alors monsieur monsieur dupuis
27 octobre 2008 est toujours directeur
général d'haïti construction au seul
endroit où il est toujours à l'acheter
qu construction mais monsieur desjardins
va quitter avec ses lunettes fumées